لم تريد ايران ان تتاخر عن عالم المال
والخدمه الماليه فواظبت على تنظيم معرضها
هذا بالعاصمه طهران لمشاركه شركات محليه
من مختلف مجالات القطاع المالي سياسه تبحث
من خلالها ايران عن شركاء خارجيين
وتبدو روسيا الجديده للشركه الايرانيه
فالعقوبه المفروضه على البلدين قربت
بينهما
كان لدينا تعاون في السابقين مع شركات
فرنسيه اما اليوم فنتعاون مع شركات روسيه
خصوصا في الخدمات التقنيه لتحليل سوق
الاستثمار والبورصه لكننا لا نزال نواجه
مشاكل في جذر مستثمرين اجانب بسبب
العقوبات اتخذت موسكو وطاهره خطوات لتسهيل
التجاره الثنائيه وتعزيز التواصل بين
مؤسستهما الماليه امر ادى الى زياده
المبادلات التجاريه بين الجانبين الى
اربعه مليارات دولار خلال العام الماضي
امين
عقد شركات مع جهات اجنبيه لتنويع
تعاملاتها الماليه وتجاوز العقوبات
المفروضه عليها
لم يستطع النظام المصرفي الايراني تجاوز
تداعيات العقوبات حتى اللحظه وهو ما دفع
الحكومه للعمل على تنويع السياساتها
المصرفيه فلم تغفل عن جلب استثمارات
اجنبيه الى البورصه حيث ارتفع مؤشرها
بثمانيه وعشرين في المئه خلال العام
الماضي الا ان قطاع التامين لا يزال يواجه
مشاكل ترتبط اساسا بالعقوبات
بكل تاكيد العقوبات لها تاثير على
اقتصادنا لكن حرفيتنا وقدرتنا جعلتانا نحد
منه وقد اتخذنا العديد من الخطوات في مجال
الاستثمار وفي التامين والمصارف وكلما
زادت الضغوط الامريكيه تمكنا من ايجاد
حلول جديده
ممكن مركزي الايراني ان اجراءات عده في
مجال الخدمه الماليه ساهمت في تعزيز حجم
التبادل التجاري لارانا مع دول العالم في
عام 2022 اذا ارتفع ب 30% عن العام الذي
سبقه كما تسال حكومه للاستفاده من الموقع
الجغرافي للبلاد كما مر تجاري يعزز
ارادتها العامه بسبعه مليارات دولار سنويا
نور الدين دغير الجزيره طهران